The mystery behind Rey's parentage has buzzed
around in Star Wars fans' minds since director
J.J. Abrams' The Force Awakens introduced
us to Daisy Ridley's scrappy Jakku-born scavenger.
We learned via a mysterious "Force vision"
that Rey's parents orphaned her as a child,
though audiences never learned their names
or saw their faces.
Who are they?
Rian Johnson's The Last Jedi offered up an
answer, if Adam Driver's Kylo Ren is to be
believed: Rey's parents were insignificant,
low-life junkers who sold her for drinking
money.
But apparently that's not what Abrams had
in mind when he was considering how to answer
the question of Rey's parentage.
According to actor Simon Pegg, who played
Unkar Plutt in The Force Awakens, Abrams'
plan was different than what we saw in The
Last Jedi.
Pegg hinted at Abram's intentions on MTV correspondent
Josh Horowitz's Happy Sad Confused podcast.
"I know what J.J. kind of intended, or at
least what was sort of being chucked around.
I think that's kind of been undone slightly
by the last one."
"There was some talk about, you know, a kind
of relevant lineage for her.
But I don't know, and I don't know if anybody
knows."
There are still a ton of theories floating
around, but whether Abrams meant for the trilogy
to eventually reveal Rey as a descendant of
the Skywalker clan or a member of the Kenobi
family tree, or something else altogether,
remains a mystery.
But Pegg's comment reveals at the very least
that Abrams' intentions weren't in line with
Johnson's later handling of the parentage
question.
Still, this all hinges on the assumption that
Johnson intended Kylo Ren's explanation to
be truthful.
There's evidence to the contrary: Johnson
previously revealed that "anything's still
open" when it comes to who Rey really is and
where she truly came from.
Just as Johnson took over the story from Abrams
after The Force Awakens, Abrams is grabbing
the baton and stepping back into the director's
seat for Episode 9.
Abrams may very well undo what was revealed
in The Last Jedi, delivering a twist that
allows his original vision for Rey's origins,
whatever that may be, to come full circle.
After all, Kylo Ren may just have lied and
told the clearly powerful Rey that she's a
nobody from a family of "filthy junk traders"
to get her to join him in his twisted galactic
conquest.
The truth may be a whole lot more hopeful,
and will hopefully be revealed when Star Wars:
Episode 9 is released on December 20th, 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!